[Música]
Hoy se celebra en el mundo el día de la
lucha contra el sida por lo que Naciones
Unidas insta a todos y cada uno de
nosotros abordar las desigualdades que
están frenando El Progreso para poner
fin a esta enfermedad este año se
pretende impulsar a la sociedad a
trabajar en todas aquellas acciones
necesarias para abordar las
desigualdades y también ayudar a poner
fin al sida pero mientras todo esto
ocurre también hay una iniciativa
internacional para encontrar una vacuna
eficaz contra esta enfermedad por ello
saludamos entonces a nuestra primera
invitada del día ya es Ana Céspedes
directora general mundial de operaciones
de la iniciativa Internacional de la
vacuna contra el CD por supuesto nos
acompaña en esta mesa de trabajo nuestra
periodista especializada en salud más
Romero sala mar también bienvenida
Gracias Raúl muy buenos días Ana la
saludo Gracias por estar con nosotros
buena mañana de jueves y primero
pongamos en contexto esta enfermedad
Cómo están las cifras del Sida en todo
el mundo hoy por hoy
Raúl Mar buenos días un placer estar
aquí con vosotros pues actualmente hay
cuarenta millones de personas que viven
con sida cada año se infectan uno coma
cinco millones de personas y mueren
700.000 y Raúl muy importante casi
100.000 son niños Este es el estado del
sida a día de hoy
Sí así es también Cuáles serían entonces
las comunidades más afectadas a por esta
enfermedad y dónde
desafortunadamente las comunidades más
afectadas es el África subsahariana
donde más de un 40% de las infecciones
de sida se producen y sobre todo mujeres
jóvenes y adolescentes Raúl estos son
los colectivos que tenemos que proteger
más en este momento
Ana hablábamos de la innovación también
de la investigación que se está haciendo
alrededor de por ejemplo una posible
vacuna contra el VIH hay aproximadamente
unas 20 veía en la página de la
iniciativa en ensayos clínicos Cuál es
Cuáles son las líneas de investigación
pues la gran dificultad que tiene la
vacuna del sidamar es que el sida es de
alguna manera desde el punto de vista de
enfermedades infecciosas el reto más
complejo por tres razones y explicaremos
un poco las vacunas como las abordan una
es un virus que muta muy rápidamente
actualmente tenemos 60 cepas dominantes
en todo el mundo ten en cuenta que por
ejemplo estamos hablando de covid
tenemos una cepa Delta pero en el caso
de
del sida tenemos 60 cepas la segunda
razón es que es un virus que ataca
nuestro sistema inmunitario desde alguna
manera lo que necesitamos para
protegernos está impactado directamente
y la tercera es que se esconde es un
virus que genera reservorios y esos
reservorios latentes cuando
el sistema inmunitario de alguna manera
se relaja vuelven otra Vera a actuar
entonces hay bastantes vacunas pero
están en fases muy preliminares están en
fase unas la mayoría a nivel mundial
solamente tenemos tres vacunas de
eficacia una vacuna en fase tres y dos
vacunas en fase dos y la previsión es
que los resultados desafortunadamente no
vayan a ser positivos claro y además
también Bueno siempre tenemos que
recordar que tenemos que tener paciencia
con este tipo de cosas que las vacunas
estén ensayos clínicos no significa que
terminen tampoco en un buen Puerto
exactamente qué tipo de terapias o de
objetivos tienen estas vacunas No si nos
puedes detallar un poco más
el área más relevante en este momento es
la producción de lo que se denomina
anticuerpos altamente neutralizantes se
ha visto estudiando el sida llevamos 50
años con esta pandemia y se ha visto que
hay personas que son capaces de producir
un tipo de anticuerpos claro el virus
varía tanto que no te vale cualquier
anticuerpo para neutralizar el virus hay
personas que producen anticuerpos
altamente neutralizantes estamos
desarrollando y allá y está haciendo
esto vacunas que sean capaces de
producir no solo protección frente al
virus sino protección frente a las
distintas de virus y estas mar son las
vacunas que se prevén que vayan a de
alguna manera abordar el problema que
tenemos de base porque serán capaces de
neutralizar no solo las variantes
existentes sino las futuras y
necesitamos que que produzcan ese tipo
de anticuerpos directamente Ana también
yo le quería preguntar con todo lo que
vimos en la pandemia y la tecnología
usadas en la vacuna de ARN mensajero
esto aumentaría digamos las
posibilidades de un avance realmente una
vacuna eficaz contra el VIH
totalmente Raúl es una pregunta
excelente en nosotros hicimos la primera
vacuna que ha producido lo que va a ser
la el paso preliminar a la producción de
anticuerpos altamente neutralizantes ha
sido una Revolución que ha pasado no ha
pasado desapercibida pero no ha tenido
todo el alcance que hubiera podido tener
hace hace un año y medio Porque
estábamos en el momento de covid una
vacuna que desarrolló allá bien fase uno
con resultados positivos estamos
repitiendo ese ensayo con moderna para
trabajar si además de utilizando
proteínas que es lo que nosotros
habíamos utilizado podemos utilizar ARN
mensajero y este año veremos los
resultados Raúl porque eso permitiría
poder avanzar más rápido por supuesto
estaremos atentos también a esos
resultados más en el en el lado social
de las vacunas de lo que estábamos
hablando vimos lo que ha sucedido con
las vacunas contra el 19 un gran ejemplo
de algo que ya venía sucediendo antes no
En caso de que se llegue a buen Puerto y
tengamos una vacuna contra el VIH Cómo
hacer para que esta vacuna llegue a esas
comunidades que nos estabas diciendo que
hoy en día son las más afectadas
qué importante mar esto que dices porque
no solo es tener la innovación es
tenerla accesible allá ves una
organización sin ánimo de lucro nos
financian gobiernos de todo el mundo nos
financian organizaciones filantrópicas
como Gates y Nuestro objetivo es el
acceso mundial entonces en nuestro caso
una vacuna que desarrollase hay alguien
tiene como objetivo prioritario lo que
son países con lowing cantantes países
con pocos recursos y este es el foco que
que nosotros tenemos no puedo hablar del
foco que tendrían otras organizaciones
pero pero este es el nuestro Ana qué más
están haciendo ustedes para digamos
acelerar un poco más toda esta
investigación o para lograr tan la tan
anhelada vacuna como lo dice se hace
muchísimo tiempo si está trabajando en
ella y pues todavía no se ha logrado
faltaría más financiación faltaría más
voluntad política en su opinión que
faltaría digamos en la comunidad
científica también en general para poder
llegar a este fin
pues es una pregunta muy importante Raúl
hace falta ser resiliente que se dice
aquí en Estados Unidos resilien porque
nosotros allá viene hace 25 años y hasta
hace cinco años estábamos absolutamente
dedicados a vacunas de sida hemos ido a
lo largo de estos cinco años utilizando
esta investigación para covid para
tuberculosis para otras enfermedades
infecciosas emergentes pero no podemos
abandonar sida allá había hecho cuarenta
ensayos han resultado negativos el año
hace un año y medio dos años tuvimos
este resultado positivo en anticuerpos
altamente neutralizantes es una
revolución científica pero es un primer
paso que va a requerir años de trabajo
entonces hay que ser resistente
necesitamos una colaboración
internacional no hay ningún país que De
manera exclusiva pueda permitir la
financiación de una línea de
investigación tan larga y tan compleja
con una con un riesgo tan tan alto
entonces necesitamos colaboración
internacional hay una organización que
se llama sepi que genera líneas de
investigación a nivel mundial Gate es un
gran contribuidor el gobierno americano
tenemos la fortuna de ser grandes
colaboradores con ellos y necesitamos
más gobiernos colaborando de manera
conjunta Raúl porque no el desarrollo de
una vacuna para sida es tan complejo Que
desde el punto de vista de inversión
privada no es rentable